so I'd say if you combined rush-hour and
bridesmaids you would get the heat
starring Sandra Bullock and Melissa
McCarthy from the director of
bridesmaids the Sandra Bullock is an FBI
agent in this movie and Melissa McCarthy
plays a detective they're both after
basically the exact same thing and they
both have different personal things that
are connected to this case that they're
both trying to solve except Melissa
McCarthy is way more street like she's
just does things her way she doesn't
wear a uniform or anything she just
walks around beats people up essentially
does whatever she wants Sandra Bullock
is the more straight-laced uptight I'm
gonna do this by the book kind of
officer and so they clash as they try to
solve this case and we get a buddy cop
movie that's pretty cliched very
predictable and actually not that bad I
am extremely surprised because I saw the
trails for the heat and I thought it
looked awful I really thought it looked
terrible and I like Melissa McCarthy and
Sandra Bullock and so I was watching
this trailer just like oh but this movie
actually did have me laughing
consistently despite the cliches and the
predictability I like these two
characters and had really great
chemistry with one another and despite
the fact that I do basically every
single beat that was gonna be happening
in this movie I found myself enjoying it
quite a bit don't look at this movie and
think well it stars two girls it's not
gonna be raunchy this movie is more
raunchy than a lot of the male centric
comedies I've seen this year and largely
because of Melissa McCarthy who is a
force of nature in this movie she is
very good a little annoying at times
with not because of her performance it
was really her character that was
supposed to be annoying but it becomes
sort of a lovable annoying after a while
and you sort of understand why she is
the way she is and there's actually a
surprising amount of underlying depth
between these characters and I was
really shocked by that and it was really
those two characters that continue to
save the movie for me and that's why I
continue to be interested in watching it
and there were some side elements to the
movie with different supporting
characters like Marlon Wayans for
instance shows up I liked his character
and I thought he added a surprising
amount of maturity to the movie actually
because generally the Wayans brothers
aren't really known for like mature
humor but he actually did a pretty good
job in the film I thought oh no the heat
is definitely a movie that will give you
some laughs I think it's easy though to
be annoyed by this movie and maybe
possibly hate it if you saw this movie
or like wow that really got under my
skin I hated it because I couldn't stand
Melissa McCarthy's character or Sandra
Bullock's character I wouldn't be like
oh yeah it's you dumb you're stupid I'd
be like yeah
I can see that but I can also see you
going into this movie and having a good
time because of the characters I think
the characters continued to make this
movie interesting and fun to watch and
even though you know that each beat
that's coming and you can see where
things are going it was an enjoyable
time overall I will say that there was
one scene that I felt went way too far
with a knife and one scene that I felt
went way too far with a straw like these
two scenes I was like what like it was
just totally out of nowhere it didn't
seem to fit in the movie at all it was
just like this strange sudden burst of
violent comedy I didn't really get it
and it didn't really work for me but for
the most part I enjoy the heat it is
predictable it is cliched it's nothing
really remarkable or special but if you
go into the heat for some laughs I would
say you're gonna get them I'm gonna give
the heat of B - because from a comedy
standpoint I go there to laugh and I
laughed quite a bit in this movie
largely because I'm Melissa McCarthy and
Sandra Bullock's comedic chemistry
thanks a lot guys for watching I
appreciate it and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes